greetings in podcast Ville it's Monday
the 27th of April get your [ __ ] together
[ __ ] take this [ __ ] mealy
[Music]
mother-in-law downstairs nagging you you
built your empire and now living it you
[ __ ] the guest this week is my brother
somebody I have to apologize to on the
air mr. Jimmy Choo shoes Schubert out of
Philadelphia one of my early mentors in
the comedy game he had a movie he was
shooting over in Korea on the 16th and
17th and 18th of March and I nearly
[ __ ] went to his house because he had
me so worried I love my friends no I did
I'd love to the input actually was March
2nd through the 9th and I was doing like
that yeah second season of the show I
had already done the first season but I
guess like people said he but I actually
tell you the truth I I was wearing a
mask back then I knew it was serious
when I got the career like everybody's
wearing masks there's such a smaller
over there they're not as big as they
are now old before you went to Korea
when you signed the plane did you write
out a will did you tell your mother
goodbye dude I wish I had gloves
I had God was item man I called you we
got on that plane you know I would say
dude if I waited too long I couldn't get
out of it and believe me I'm glad I did
it cuz that money's gonna get me through
this pandemic but Jesus man I would they
were I was nervous but I was also like
I'm just gonna just social distance and
wear my mask and gloves and goggles I
wasn't playing games in a March 2nd the
stress had developed as much people as
me I saw it March 2nd at the Comedy
Store and I was done back in February I
was in Atlantic City at the Hard Rock
Casino and even then I had lights on my
room's frame I wasn't touching any know
everything already in federal no why
would you unless they stop when
billionaires stop with the NBA and the
NA challenges stop when they're gonna
lose billions of dollars I went to set
them up here something's something's
real then you were monitoring it and I
just said there's something else that
maybe
not telling us so I wasn't taking any
chances I hate gloves I'm a little bit
of a prepper I had I already had the m95
occasion like that just a little box of
the n95 mask I had the rubber gloves I
had to goggles I mean just because you
never I'd rather I'd rather have that
sorry yeah so and sure enough when I was
going I had the gloves I had the mask to
bag did I get two masks got a cloth mask
over top of that 95 mass but I wasn't
taking any chances
I just wasn't I mean I was it like even
when I thought about you every day every
day like everything right I call that
I'm Tom like to allow you back in the
comedy store that you were a mother
[ __ ] I mean I gotta do it I can't I
gotta save my people this [ __ ] guy
went into the heart of Korea then I call
you a weakling you like I'm having a
great time I'm in Boston with Lenny
Clarke he's gonna kill another one of my
idols no no no I dude I was I did I was
I was putting that stuff on I was social
distancing what pissed me off was when I
called you you said you came back that
even bother you no tests no hello no
welcome to America there's a [ __ ]
epidemic coming here well I'm also a
citizen I mean the lines for people
coming in from other places that was
like hardcore but with me I okay so me
had a goggle sided mask I am a hoodie up
I had to bag masks on a rubber glove yes
take all the you know all that stuff off
once I get in and he saw my face because
yeah but they didn't they didn't they
didn't stop they took my temperature
before I left Korea twice good day yeah
yeah b1 okay they do it over there not
they were liked it twice they it's part
of the new worm who things yeah yeah
they were taking they took your
temperature twice and on the way back
Joey there was nobody I had 15 seats for
only 15 see nobody was in my section of
a business class there was nobody in
there I was like this is awesome you
know I mean and that you know they had
the curtains drawn there was another
section another section but the section
I was in nobody was in there so I wasn't
worried on the way back on the way over
there was really not a lot of people
around me
so I'm Nadia I was at the park with my
daughter I had just gotten back from
Vegas and I just called you to check in
now they're like I'm going to Korean I'm
like I thought it was like a bad dream
but at this time I didn't know
architecture either
so that was my fault you know I don't
I'm not good with geography once you say
I'm going to the Philippines I'm
thinking everything's to China at that
time yeah
at that time I thought all the Asian
countries and I have nothing against
them I wasn't blaming anybody
right I was just like Jimmy you're not
gone yeah
but believe me I can I call him called
your manager I told him I said hey you
got to get me out of this he goes well
he goes were committed you leave it like
that I was leaving that money goes you
can't do this to these guys and I going
so I went but also I looked up to South
Korea and the infection in South Korea
was in the gas which is like Oh like
it's like 500 miles from where I was
going Seoul is a city of 11 million
people and they only had 100 cases and I
was checking they were doing
drive-through testing they were already
on top of us so I said I'm going for a
week I could get in I get out I'm only
gonna set three days and I'll just go
hit-and-run this social distance and I
did and thank God nothing happened but
you're right I was a little nervous but
it also prepped me for everything else
that was where a mask
I went even in Boston I had a mask on
and they were like kind of making fun of
me then I got in Lenny Lenny Clarke
picked me up
you know he's one of my heroes as well I
got a mask off I don't want to kill I
want to kill any side of masks on my you
know I finally like social distancing
and stuff when you were there but it was
like I mean that was it I knew I didn't
once I got to the end of March I knew I
was good
[Laughter]
I mean how do you feel I feel great man
I'm walking doing a test or anything and
he covet any antibody test are you
interested yeah I would do a test see I
would do a test but I know I know I'm
good
did I take my vitamins in the morning
that I've been walking every day I've
been walking every day five miles a day
the last two days we did six miles with
our boy Steve Simone
we got Lisa head out there a little
early just trying to get reading up
there just getting that sunshine minutes
I just read this the other day the
sunshine even 20 minutes of the Sun the
body produces microbacterial that's like
viruses and parasites and everything
else yeah we were there for an hour and
a half walking six miles I thought
that's even better
parasites you were talking about you
know what happens when you eat hummus
cut into worms inside so you're saying
like you gotta realize any weight beef
what's in the beef when you eat all this
[ __ ] you're reading what's in it
yeah there's toxins in it and your body
needs to get rid of them yeah so the
best way to feed but yeah your body
pisses some of the mouth yeah sometimes
you take a [ __ ] that smells like 10
horses died oh my god I've got three or
four of those a day that's nature's
penicillin as nature's penicillin then I
make my wife how many solid closes a
recipe call for but you know white
people they stick to the recipe three
garlic cloves didn't put six yeah well
it won't taste the same will taste
better it's garlic
yeah and I'll [ __ ] blood and it clean
I'm a big garlic dude always have been
with Bob Lowe
sent me the Capitol's I was like ah I
thought in the old days like my mom when
I was a kid used to make me Klose butter
with Cuban bread and olive oil now when
I first came from I still remember what
garlic you mean garlic on the bread no
[ __ ] cook garlic like raw raw garlic
with olive oil and whatever you know I
just stunk like [ __ ] a vampire you
know what I do I take that the cloves of
garlic chopped them up I put this and
this stuff called manuka honey it's like
a superfood it's like you know it's like
it cost like 20 30 bucks but it is raw
super unscrewed and I put the garlic
right in the honey and I swallow it it
helps me get it down but you're right
you take dumb spore they stink but I'd
rather I'd rather I'm telling you that's
nature's penicillin I'd rather take it
like you said Simone goes I think I put
too much garlic in the sauce I go give
it a man go go yeah like it you know you
we live in California which you know
most people listen to this year I live
in California you live in Arizona with
some people in New York or some people
in England with you
it's [ __ ] cloudy every day whatever
the [ __ ] you know you I like I love the
Sun yeah the best Sun I've ever been out
in front of his Colorado was a kid that
go to Aspen you want ten minutes we came
back with her people going you come from
Jamaica yeah you're 12,000 feet higher
than most people or 14,000 feet yeah I
went out and bought SPF and I would put
on and pitch right and come home and let
people be like why the [ __ ] so I fell in
love with the Sun I've always liked the
Sun yeah I never knew the healing
properties of you know how good the Sun
is right now there's no pollution don't
go down Laurel Canyon and see how look
how much you get far how far you can
look into it really today take a ride
forth life just to change it up what was
the last time with the Hollywood Lee
never amongst okay today just 4:30 when
you think it's supposed to be traffic
you get in your car go below you see all
the way out there all the way it is the
most spectacular thing you have ever
seen no no used to see it before yeah
now you can actually see that little
house that has a porch sitting in front
of it and kids playing you could see all
the clearness in the air so the air has
been the best that's ever been they
showed the air in new Delfy
yeah ever do without you can see that
you could see the Himalayas but
it's tremendous now so good that no no
father's disease is not staying home
it's getting out it's getting out oh but
get out of the Sun no I avoid people
yeah don't we do this walk within the
neighborhood just don't buddy back there
there's blue birds under sea blue birds
butterflies real finches I mean you walk
through you see all this stuff that you
never get like what's the last time you
seen this there's birds everywhere
they're you know the flowers are
blooming
I always stay away from people we do a
social distance walking but it's it's
great to get out I'm telling you I feel
great and this is a little this'll be
day seven seven days I have at least
five miles a day what were you doing for
the first couple of weeks we just home I
know you're a single guy I mean how is
it feeling for you at the house well you
know what I these were you getting those
couple days you know though like I like
after like I like Glade raffling three
days there was get me down I missed
doing stand-up I said how long is this
going to lon I was kind of I had a
freakout and then I said you don't want
no get up every day I started reading
books I got I'm reading four books I got
one by the one by the the toilet one by
my bed one by my couch so I got books
going I got that I'm watched a couple
documentaries I'm catching up on some
stuff and want to catch up on and
redecorated my joint I'm turning my back
bedroom into like a little social media
studio I'm just I'm gonna keep myself
busy I'm walking I'm eating healthy I'm
cooking I'm learning how to cook some
stuff that I wanted to cook that I
couldn't cook I tried that look I'm just
trying to stay positive I'm trying to
stay focused you're right this thing can
beat you up but you got to make a
decision I mean I'm gonna beat you up
physical mental hard what's the word
it's kind of like the beating you're
taking already you're going into a fight
with a financial stigma going into your
head yeah you're about to lose
everything
yeah so you can do two things you can
sit down where we kill yourself you know
I'm not listen things work out furlough
you know unemployment and they all work
out whatever but then
I think there's more like I read an
article a time about how kids from this
generation are affected I have her
involved all day she's been gone since
8:15 this morning yeah you know I don't
let her she's waiting for me right now
to hit the mix because she gets three
stars I get her outside throwing punches
she throws the 9 pound ball right now so
I put myself on the schedule it's been a
blessing to have her usually you want to
shoot yourself she says some dear that
makes you laugh you know yeah I got a
hash you about something else now
because you mentioned it I mean more
than me and more than any of these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
calling themselves comedians with no
class you have been a veteran of two
comedy Wars here you were a veteran of
Kennison days at the commies through
which our history history and then these
last seven years which has been a great
run at the store absolutely we all know
as human being that's gonna take a
minute to get it back yeah to where it
was all our businesses every other club
in the country you know yeah what do you
see happening for yourself economy for
the year and as a whole well I'm glad
you brought it up I'm in May 15th I got
a brand new album dropping called zero
tolerance it's coming out you know the
on Sirius XM but it also be available on
all the streaming platforms on may 15th
right two months iTunes yeah I think
it's one of my best albums so I got that
coming out and I'm also working I mean
I'm just keeping keeping write what I
think will happen is that's what I think
I think if you got a comedy club that
seats 300 people that comedy club will
now seat 150 they'll do some social
distance seating initially so people
aren't sitting right next to each other
until they get back to the point where
everybody feels comfortable but I think
so the money's gonna drop I think a lot
of the clubs have struggled like that
like the understood like that the desert
the the servers and
lottie's people are having a tough time
make a living so I think it's gonna come
back a little bit gradually but I do
think eventually it will come all the
way back I think people want to hear
what comedians have to say about this
this is a whole new I mean you know that
you say you survived a pandemic you can
say that when you get to that point and
people are gonna want to hear what you
have to say about it I think people need
to laugh more than ever now I mean you
know I don't and people doing these
virtual [ __ ] comedy shows I'm gonna
[ __ ] knock it off could we stop with
the Fuhrer I seen you in front of a
packed house on a Saturday night go down
like an Iraqi fighter pilot what makes
you think you'll be any funnier from
your [ __ ] living room your wife just
[ __ ] walked out of the living room we
taper you said stop it it's look man the
cats making a rope to hang himself I
swear to god you're up there with you
[ __ ] cruise ship [ __ ] act your I
was right I've seen those things and I
love listen much respect for giving it a
shot it doesn't work for me look you
ever see a guy gets up dummy ask about
mistakes it looks fun a lot of fun some
guys struggling it's like a little
reprieve you know I'm saying some big
black do this [ __ ] women ears yeah yeah
that looks like fun to do that to
somebody on March 2nd i sat here with
Lee and play Johnny genius I know me and
Lee gonna get the pantry ongoing and
charge 10 bucks a month and I was going
to move that chair put that couch slide
it down and put some own Eric Rocha
Lee Lee and sand bean dowry in here Rene
yeah and just do a night of new material
every night tonight's topic draw it out
of a hat penises boom
three minutes yeah three minutes I
thought this was gonna work and then I
was like I'm gonna kill them we're gonna
kill each other there's somebody's gonna
get the corona
right because I knew just sitting there
by myself wasn't really gonna cut it
I just know I just know you need that
energy you need that now I know it
there's people that have certain
platforms that they have people watching
you and that laughter
delayed people are really trying yeah
god bless them you know what for me I'm
taking a breather I'm with you I'm
taking a breather I mean I've been
approached to do a couple I'm just not I
mean like I mean realistically it's been
a [ __ ] month like you've been a
you've been by yourself from I get it
some people don't have the skill set but
I certainly don't want you sitting in
your living room with a [ __ ] ukulele
doing [ __ ] song parodies like
everybody turns into Weird Al Yankovic I
go don't you have something else that
like it's like it's not doing anything
for me is these people are [ __ ]
turning like you know [ __ ] Karen's a
[ __ ] expert on infectious diseases
like shut some dude shaved his [ __ ]
chest hair into a bat signal and dyed it
blue you're gonna be quarantined for a
[ __ ] three weeks hey you're about
Tommy Esposito now what happened he
sucked a dick is he gay no he was just
bored one quarantine decided to see what
he's missing yeah like people back at
the [ __ ] off but don't he put a couple
weeks well I mean is this what comics
talk about I always your comics
complain all the roads boring you're by
yourself in a hotel room it sounds like
that's kind of cool you guys have been
preparing for this look up for me I'm
not I'm doing fine I've been quarantined
for years I like being by myself I get
it but there's also people that have
mental issues that don't do well and
stuff like this and need human contact
or whatever yeah okay you know ever
since the beauty salons closed with the
nail salons ever selfies have dropped
like the stock market ain't nobody
[ __ ] posted selfies don't want
everybody the eyelashes are falling off
they gotta get the bacon ready but
you're not able to wax your back it's
[ __ ] you know just those the [ __ ]
readout it isn't served I think it's a
hard set for Humanity I think it's a
hard reset for you man I think a lot of
people have taken things for granted
we've got you can place it thank you
we've little things thank you turns out
now are the big things too handshakes
hugging your friends tell the jokes
having a drink having some laughs
together I'm telling you man you'll
never take that [ __ ] for granted ever
again
and but we have we have we've been mean
to each other you know what you realize
is this is proven to me the
planet earth is a giant human eco sphere
and we're all kind of connected what
hurts the guy in the other side of the
world hurts me as well and that we
should all [ __ ] learn to what I do
have faith in is that we got some of the
smartest minds in the world trying to
solve this problem and we're all united
in one cause I think I think we need to
be more like that I think people need to
be more like that I think people need to
be finder you see someone struggling
stop help them up don't be a mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] be kind I think that you
see like even nature like the airs
things clear as it's been rivers are
coming back Fisher were like
repopulating and maybe this was mutt
mother nature's way of gonna hey listen
we live on a planet where anything kill
you spiders snakes Carol Baskin a lot of
shaky [ __ ] tape on a planet but this
is I think it's just a real hard reset
for you Manny and I think you should
just like you said on the way in people
doing some of that big work up top doing
work they haven't thought inside school
nobody's really thought this high school
yeah you get into high school college
and the SATs BC T's resumes you move
from Emerson you're in an apartment you
don't know what's going on yeah they're
charging you for parking that you know
you've never had a chance to really sit
down with your own outside glee and I
gotta tell you this I tell you this
seriously you know how what this workout
and I've been telling you is it's a form
of meditation yeah to let you know it's
okay when you get back from walking with
Steve I want you to go upstairs take off
your pants immediately take off your
shirt don't eat none don't sit on your
couch jump in the shower you get out and
this is where the true meditation comes
in this is what's going to build your
heart is to stretch it and at the end of
the stretching sitting for the best
amount of time that you can even if you
laid down and yoga they call it huh
savasana and just realize at the end of
the award
my heart down and this is what's helped
me the last couple weeks to just heart
first week the two that I was hittin the
bag guys I was five minutes away from a
stroke yeah I was scared to death
because the fear was coming up my neck
that's true type [ __ ] but I would punch
through the fear they just kept on hooks
and digging into the body like Rocky
yeah and it's it seemed you know I was
so scared that the first five minutes of
anything I did
whether it was bodyweight squats I
wouldn't need five minutes just to relax
my heart and mind would spin out of
control so this has become like I'm back
to meditate
yeah oh good man it just calms it all
down close your eyes turn read focus on
your nose and breathing and let
everything go away your mother your
father the cat you know what you can't
pay rent
Oh get the [ __ ] yeah let [ __ ] Tommy
Lamas say anything we just release just
release I do that every day after my
workout outside in the heat of the Sun
sweat and I gotta wipe my eyebrows while
I'm doing it I just sit there but my
fingers together as gay as it sounds I
give gratitude for what I have I give
gratitude for what I don't have and I
know Jesus Christ I just finish the work
I don't know live another day regardless
all these people they're showing you the
tools and their noses and you know it's
just we gotta be very fortunate yeah III
think I think you're right i think that
daily gratitude I've been doing that you
know I would say my rosary every night
this is it I would say I'm a six again
nobody I mean you don't say my rose
before I go to bed tonight I pray for
the front liners the EMTs the doctors
and nurses the people that are really on
the front lines of this thing my family
my friends the people I love them care
about and in the morning I do that
stretch and get up the stretch and I do
that meditation I'm telling you it's the
only thing keeps me sane it does I don't
watch I don't even turn on my TV I don't
the news no no more you know when I got
on the moves at six yeah this is Cartman
well I'm moving around and eating dinner
but no more sitting in front of my buddy
dude I'm a buddy gaming his gift a while
back was one of those old-style iPods
and it literally has every top 40 song
in every category from like 1955 through
2013 it's got the entire Beatles
collection it's got the theme song for
it for the TV shows that you grew up
watching yeah I mean it's got everything
150 Giga budget and I just pick an
artist like yeah there that was Pink
Floyd BAM all day long with the Pink
Floyd just listening Led Zeppelin Billie
Joe you know just listening to music and
I don't I don't watch it it calms me no
you can't watch you watch that new show
you you you've been underneath the end
table working on a callus of the roof of
your mouth from a load of revolver
you don't mean I can't you know you
can't know what I was doing I was
watching from I love being scared I was
watching the news from three to four
solid watch well I won't you know
Eyewitness News
yeah locally and then the World News
Tonight with David Muir at four o'clock
I'd be shaken and that's how I would
force myself to go outside and hit the
bag yeah that's one of my stress levels
were so high then I said let me try it
without watching the news I was
muhammad' I leave it I was bouncing
stinging you know what I did it but when
[ __ ] Sugar Ray Leonard's by myself
and I go that's it no more news about
two years ago more news about two years
ago I [ __ ] had the cable company come
get the Box yeah get this out of my
house why do you think they call a
[ __ ] programming people sitting
around just putting fear in your head
it's put controlling it with fear you
know I want to say this too before we
get on off on a tangent of people are
big fans of comedy here you get to
church family but a lot of comedians
that you support like you said no one's
working but if you go to Pandora and
Spotify and you listen to some of your
favorite artists it helps them get you
know a little bit of money at the end of
each month like you know so a lot of
guys are like hey you know just go
listen to some of your favorite artists
and help some outlet comedians and
whatnot so it's a good thing to you know
it's like we're not working either
I don't know
I'm gonna go back I don't know when it's
gonna come back so you know it's a way
to way to help out some of your favorite
comedians you go listen to the stuff
whoever it is go listen one Spotify aped
door and you know to get a couple get a
couple pennies on every song or whatever
the deal is but it helps out are you
willing to get on planes tomorrow are
you ready to get on planes
I would go on a plane tomorrow you know
I got a I got a it's it's funny I had
this corporate gig that got canceled was
supposed to be like you know March 28th
so they moved into May 20th now they're
talking about virtual doing a virtual
shell I said well listen tell I mean I'm
making any money I'll do it you already
paid me half but I'll do it but you know
the price with the process you know I
mean I didn't have anything to do with
this and just and so I'll do the virtual
comedy show I'll do some stuff I said if
you're gonna do that I said make sure
you have people on the other thing so
you can cut to meet telling a joke and
then you can cut to like the 20 people
on the other side of zoom laughing and
stuff so it makes it seem like it's a
real comedy show like I said so if you
have the people call Lane I mean it's
for Gilda's house I want to raise that
money help out but have like that 20
people sitting there so I can do the job
to cut to me then you cut to them to me
tell another that way it seems like a
comedy show if you're gonna do it do it
that way you know and then maybe we can
do a Q&A and they can ask me anything
and we can do the you know the time or
whatever I mean listen I'd loved I mean
other than I don't know what other than
that I don't know what to do and I don't
know when it's gonna come back to full
swing I'm just hoping that doesn't go on
for too long I don't want to become a
solo artist on [ __ ] pornhub under the
name of pinky everything I'm trained to
do it's not acting I mean you had the
kids so that thing with the Sopranos
ever if I can pick that up would you
ever go back to do that or no what are
you yeah I mean it's it's like what I
think or stand up or anywhere I you know
even [ __ ] do I'm looking at things
right now going how are they gonna do
this how are they gonna do that I got a
call last week and they said that they
pushed the movie back yeah till March 12
and
that once things slowed down they would
try to put the band back together to
shoot that one st. well I my response
was we'll have to see when that scene is
at what time because I'm 57 to all those
things
I'm not even travelling for comedy yeah
like I'm not traveling for Tommy I'm
holding on to my brain dating Jew yeah
I've got a Vegas July 31st which I
normally got an addendum for because
they're not gonna be able to see 1600
people on there right I've got August
30th August 1st at San Diego I have to
walk there yeah yeah and I got Salt Lake
City September 4th and 5th if they hold
on yeah you know you gotta remember what
comedian what people all know at home
and everybody knows that every every
aspect of life has a slow on a busy
season
ours is October through May is when we
thrive yeah if you wanna go on the
summer there's nothing wrong with it but
you're fighting against vacations
barbecues after school part you know
yeah Plus everything's been postponed to
delay right so they're gonna have to
make up all these other dates for all
these other shows they cancelled I doubt
that like theater acts are going back to
the clubs that's not gonna happen it's
gonna have to happen you think so I have
to happen where you gonna start
I don't think about what's Bluebell
booming Rachel does it do yeah it's
1,200 seats yeah that's gonna put you
have to put 400 again I thought out of
those dates yeah to move on until they
do open up yeah well I also I also think
that the you know the cavalry clubs are
you know they've been working either for
three months and they're gonna come back
out of this struggling a little bit and
trying to figure out how to you know
juggle all this stuff it's gonna be
it'll be interesting to see how they
start to move back but I love to go into
town I know what people are going
through yeah love to go out during the
week and crack jokes I think it's gonna
go back to Monday through Sunday yeah
comedy
we'll go back to seven nights a week
that's one thing I think so it makes
sense we're trying to get yours out if I
could get Joe Diaz to come in one day
and Tuesday yeah
and bang out seven and 940 people I'll
do it seven nights a week yeah so
schedules are gonna change that's gonna
be good you go out of town on a Tuesday
and Wednesday
yeah that's we're not gonna get the
profit margin you're gonna get the
percentages is Friday Thursday and
Saturday no but the thing is it'll start
to come back I'd like to come back and
and I think the other thing is - as long
as you you why should that because I
mean people have been quarantined for
will be almost for two months so if you
didn't have it then you don't have it I
mean you just gotta you know I'm not
gonna no one's gonna go to a NFL game
with all those people but I mean small
groups of people nothing is burning me
I'm walking and walking through the
living room and then talking about an
NFL Draft the other day and like sitting
there go the Rams got rid of
what's-his-name
I'm like guys you gotta bring back
baseball first yeah you gotta bring back
but at the den be a finals so I guess
Friday the NBA players start practicing
by themselves yeah you know what are you
gonna do that thinking you know the idea
right yeah Vegas putting every team in a
different hotel and nobody's allowed
into the house and the only play you
only go to one place to play they're
trying to put something together yeah so
nobody has to travel every Hotel in
Vegas is utilized that's empty they're
all empty nobody goes in and out except
the players and they get shoveled right
to an arena they get tested they play
Joe this is one option I heard yeah
this makes sense you know baseball
you're gonna have to go back to a third
of the thing I don't yes sit next to me
but I don't want nobody behind me yeah I
don't want a fat guy behind me yelling
go Dodgers that's not gonna happen with
hotdogs the chunk is going all over my
neck yeah you know they Dave Dave Dave
what they did they're gonna have to read
to look at planes
yeah who's sitting on plane I think
there's also new cleaning guidelines on
play yeah like germ tubes those yeah
they have to I don't think you're gonna
have that they're gonna do the cleaning
guidelines gonna be different
everything's gonna be different I think
eventually it will go back to like where
it was I did I think if there's no
second wave of this thing there is going
to be a second do you think so you know
why don't I know why Disney's not open
yeah and then you got all the liability
for that stuff to use me is not opening
till 2020 first that even if you're a
[ __ ] you're at home thinking to
yourself Disney's not opening there's me
something jack up that pixel heart
division because that they could do
anybody can work on animation by
themselves yeah they're gonna bring back
the Looney Tunes nice and we're doing
all of that stuff to it ya know got a
beef up that you know they're not it's
like some girl put well I hope they do
construction it did you see that yes
right now some girl put on there from
the church I hope they do construction
or fix some of the Disney World is that
are you [ __ ] yeah did somebody hit
you in the head with a stick though
you'd see gas in your eye
they're closing those places because
they know 70% people have to fly over
here to go up Disney wind
I got Angelenos go to Disneyland yeah I
don't think that's I don't think it they
may ban that China and that
international emigrate though that's
that stuff's done to then ain't coming
back there's no more immigration or you
ain't come under the country I think
that's gonna extend for a little while
my cousin sent me pictures of the
streets of Cuba nobody
they just extended orders in some town
in Mexico that if you see on your street
they're gonna shoot ya without a [ __ ]
head back yeah if you're on the street
without a mask in Mexico there's some
city right now a couple of them yeah but
they just stated we're just gonna shoot
you
dude I was reading this for the other
day
about in China and this is what this is
the like the scary thing there are 21
million less cellphone users since this
like virus broke out and stuff so I
think they like there's there's 21
million less cellphone users that were
for no reason just like during the vibe
though just dropped off like this does I
mean that's how they were starting to
think about the numbers and there's and
these are lying about them they did that
they know all that [ __ ] they're like
they there's a like 21 million less
cellphone years as laws talk because we
take it seriously I did you see that
what happened yesterday in Orange County
at the beach like 40,000 people were at
Newport Beach like that's why it's gonna
come back cuz a lot of people just
aren't taking it seriously listen I'm
not mad at those people no that's most
people that drive by and they see a line
and they'll pull over it's down that
line to give them comfort or warmth you
know the reason why you can't go to a
park and walk around no whole part is
because eventually three people will
walk up on him doesn't mean that bad
people it's our natural game to be close
to the angle and the social we're social
so social distancing is gonna work if
you make it work if you lay your line
and tell people stop right there yeah
did you see the thing I posted the other
day I'm at the liquor store in the Bronx
hey that's my mentality what's it my
mentality is basically this is one of
the funniest things I've ever read
hanging on a door yeah if you call your
dad you get to play either yeah yeah
that's my state of mind
I'm working my state of mind is
basically here it is plain and [ __ ]
simple if you [ __ ] if you're gonna be
that [ __ ] stupid cuz I love I love
exactly what he said he said the exact
words I would write in front of my
[ __ ] business I don't know where the
[ __ ] it is put up my safe no titty money
no
I had no soft money I can't find it
doesn't matter but that's the exact way
I feel
yeah don't be pulling [ __ ] out his sock
don't be pulling out of your breasts
he's selling live in there
that was so brilliant and this is the
one with it well he says shut the [ __ ]
up oh shut the [ __ ] up
don't shut the [ __ ] up the reason why do
I remove I do early is because I want to
do the percentages of people that have
been in that place yeah so I try to cut
it real early like I go to Walgreens at
8:15 I wanted my supermarket hope is 6
a.m. I'm the first guy Ralph's on the
corner of uh I'm gonna die there don't
go to rap got a really valid
oh yeah look at that shut the [ __ ] up
buy your [ __ ] and leave immediately
no kitty or sock money stand back at
least 6 feet player store capacity to 5
[ __ ] at watch you coffee you
die drink responsibly and it's you
that's it don't come in here with
questions yeah you know we got no lights
off why do you ask it there's a [ __ ]
141 whatever you say that like you go to
what's or what village
Valley Village it's just a small ones
it's like a little bodega yeah there's a
little Eminem market right by the corner
right there on Parker that's the one I
go to somebody turn me on to a place for
meat the end a real house wouldn't end
on a soul in there my wife made the
steak last night tasted like [ __ ]
move God's personal [ __ ] beef oh yeah
dude that M&M markets like little places
over there chicken marinade already the
sausage is fresh great sure shubik what
do you say I mean this is we've gone
through two huge [ __ ] explosions at
the Comedy Store explosion of Thank You
witnesses a young man yeah and the
explosion that you're a part of
now how long till we get it back to that
yes man I think first of all they're
only opening up one room
yeah well slowly they'll get back but
it's it's gonna take months I think it's
gonna take a lot of comics out of the
business
yeah I think yeah I think a lot of
comics are gonna rearrange their lives
and go you know this is where I was that
I've done this for 18 years
my wife is you know yeah I mean and I
feel bad for people but at the same time
I've always said that everybody's gonna
get their own personal silver lining out
of this I know for a fact yeah but I
know guys over the years Joey did like
guys that they got married they had kids
and I just said effort I'm not I'm not
I'm gonna my kids are more important my
family's more important so you know I
don't wanna be [ __ ] away from my kids
that you guys started to put coaching a
football team so we got out of comedy
all you people do you're right I think
people will hit like to go you know what
[ __ ] life's too short if I ain't doing
something I love to do if I ain't doing
something to feed myself then why do it
I think also I think other people I
think other people that do 9 to 5 jobs
you know you know what is something and
they make a one is something are
continually there it's gonna go both
ways I think if if you've taken some
time to reflect over this period you
know what am i doing
I'm gonna work for [ __ ] you know 30
years and then I got 10 years before I
die and I'm gonna live my life I mean if
anything you go do something that feeds
your [ __ ] soul I don't tell look
listen look I'd rather fail doing
something I love to do then succeed in
something I [ __ ] do it
and then I hate it then I gotta go in
everyday hate my [ __ ] life and I
gotta tell you Joey if all descended
Tamar between me and you had the most
amazing life me too
I've long I've traveled the world I've
seen I've made people laugh I've had the
greatest [ __ ] time I had a great
[ __ ] run and if I gotta figure out
something to do after this I will but I
mean I have to tell you I think it will
come back I think it will eventually get
back to where it was
but you're right it's gonna change some
things and things gonna have to come
different I think it's gonna come raging
back eventually it will get back to
where it is before this happened but
it's gonna be months I mean people just
want to feel safe you know I mean you
know you get a metal detector running
probably people taking their temperature
before they come into the club you know
I mean there's gonna be some new safety
protocols how many years you've been
doing comedies like 33 years I'm pretty
safe to say you [ __ ] love it I love
it I [ __ ] what I miss you know do let
me tell you something there's this guys
who do this there that are famous and
they do it because you know it's an
exercise I do cuz I love to do it I
really have it for a dollar a 10,000 and
I've done it for four people and I've
done it for 2,700 I mean you know I love
to do it and there's nothing that makes
me feel the way I feel after I get done
killing a crowd I mean I'm a true real
[ __ ] stand-up comic I mean I've made
every [ __ ] sacrifice of my life for
this and and I traveled I've been doing
it for 33 years and I just it's still
look I'm not I'm gonna bitter prick I
mean I know a lot of guys all good I
[ __ ] you I love what I see you at the
store you limping you're coming and you
look I remember when I first got to the
store like I'm trying to do that audio
book yeah so I'm trying to outline my
life is uh chapter one at the store and
chapter two at this boy yeah two
different scenarios at the school yeah
when I went into the store the first
time I wanted to the store as a scrub my
eyes opened my mouth shut
just learning watching you know I fell
in love with Mitzi I got to do drugs I
met my wife yeah and then I left one day
yeah and I came back with an audience
yeah complete different Joe Diaz than
the first Jody is that what it is yeah I
went in there a scrub you know host the
doorman yeah I was the doorman in the
back door on Sunday nights I drove I
know and you know there's no runner
Jackie run a jar you're get going to
your house do you cook for me
there was a monday night football game
on the broncos are playing and i called
the whole series dude he's calling the
game he goes he goes he's gonna run this
in Elway runs if he goes super dazed to
call this game this is what I did dude
it was the greatest thing we're drinking
some red wine we're eating some chili
we're watching laying around on the
floor like a couple of hugging 13 year
olds watching Monday Night Football
dude it was great that's great Jimmy was
one of my mentis I listened to what
Jimmy said he hooked me up with his
manager who's still a dear friend today
he just came to my show on Vegas yet
tears in his eyes when they saw me yeah
he loves you man we love each other we
were like the tight we were Batman's
villains
yeah that was the name of our crew Billy
Gardell we got Danny Sanchez I think you
know Sanchez he had a group of comedians
and and and then he became like this
manager and I swear to god bro are you
right I don't think like that guy I wish
I could find a guy like that kind of
yeah he doesn't exist today that's why I
said to you I've never had a person in
my career like that since oh yeah did
you talk to him in Vegas yeah he's come
out to see me a couple times yes and he
even called me one day and he's like are
you looking for a manager this is about
two years ago and I'm like I don't
really know he goes who's doing work for
you up there CA let me get the [ __ ]
phone I'm like oh his world is all gone
yeah like the people he was doing
business with it's like that scene in
The Sopranos when the the inspector
comes to inspect the house and the
Carmela's father's like get punchy
waters on the phone and he goes pudgy
retired eight years ago yeah and he's
like that's what Gavin would come back
to yeah it's a different world his his
number-one nemesis was Judy Brown Oh God
now Judy Brown would take him and throw
him off a building yeah he doesn't even
compete and that lovely no more so I
considered him because I loved them as a
manager yeah but you're right I think
that's what like he would just talk to
[ __ ] people yeah yeah anyone give a
[ __ ] dude I think there's like hey well
why
can't we I'm gonna do god bless director
got me a pilot and freaking to
development deal so you're right I mean
I thought about it too but you're right
in his world is different now it's a
different it's the difference that he
was all the fun type of dude when he
managed when he called you he called you
the rip Uehara like I still remember
being whatever this convertible one day
he picked me up to meet him for lunch we
had a meeting with an agent yeah over by
Highland that old disgusting building on
island as you made the turn up to the
101 now it's like [ __ ] beautiful
there was a building there with Bob
hotline across the street they saw porn
and I still remember he took me to see
that lady he told me right out he was
listen I present your tape everywhere at
that time CAA Moana me when I was with
he's like this is the weirdest thing
okay calls from a guy at CAA for you but
the holidays past these Swit stages so I
was [ __ ] so I still remember one day
Jeff picking me up meeting him only on
Hollywood and he drove me to this ladies
and they will call the Daniel Hoff
agency yeah and the word on the street
was to lady had quit like you know CAA
who ever at that time yeah and took her
roster to this agent and nobody know
about it she was doing great thing yeah
and I remember now I know the agency
yeah I remember hearing that agent I
remember walking in with him going I'm
not signing with these people this is an
old crickety building yeah nobody who
offered you old Hollywood bro and you
could hear her in there yelling [ __ ] you
get in the audition or don't call me
back click who's next I remember walking
in there with Jeff and going Jeff I
don't want to sign with this dude you
tell that you know what Gitlin did bro
this is a true story
I was doing a road gig I'm flying in I
got a I got a freaking audition it was
for one hour photo that sacrum was I was
playing a soccer coach for with
Williams is in the movie he picks me up
at the airport I throw my bags in his
car he drives me to the audition I can
win I [ __ ] I did a great audition I
thought I want them getting the [ __ ]
job and then he [ __ ] dropped me off at
home I mean that what where do you get a
[ __ ] manager like that in Hollywood
the guy picked me up at the [ __ ]
airport and drove me to the audition I
defy any [ __ ] manager in the industry
today I mean that's [ __ ] a man I did
he picked me up you wanna [ __ ] sit
there tell me I need more [ __ ]
Twitter followers go [ __ ] yourself I
mean this guy pick me up it was a day I
was what I was I learned so much from
him that was all [ __ ] like the
headshot theory he despised yeah he just
call you the only auditions he got me
with no headshot he's a different day he
was different dude and that's why he
couldn't last because the last
conversation I had him I heard with him
one time on the phone it was not
pleasant but I still remember going to
me like you have to meet him once a
month on his office yeah and go over
stuff with him and I still remember
hated cuz you had a park in Century City
Mall yeah I walk and cross and then you
gotta climb [ __ ] 18 floors up that
you know that girl that answered the
phone still worth in that office is that
funny that's his father's insurance
office oh yeah yeah his father's
insurance office with him yeah when we
did break up though it's like the same
thing he said to you about the end goes
I go Jeff can just get me he goes shoot
me I called everybody I said everybody
he goes I called everybody nobody wants
to be in the Jimmy Huber business like
you got [ __ ] balls bro he's trying to
sugarcoat it a little bit he didn't pour
hey guys I got everybody said nobody
wants to be the TV shows [ __ ] nobody
that I was like you know what Jeff I go
maybe
they don't want to be in a Jeff Gitlin
business and has nothing to do with me
maybe and towards the end he was like
yes coz he would tell you no indeed he
would call you the highly how you doing
uh and you're like who's this this is
Jeff Kelly you don't know who I am I'm a
manager a comedy manager I've been
watching your show on this is the most
brilliant thing he ever did in from yeah
he's like I've been watching your show
on CBS and I could tell her numbers are
going down can you imagine getting that
call somebody telling you this really
sucks I was there I was in the office
and even though your ratings are going
down I watch six episodes are you sure
you got that [ __ ] deadbeat like he
would just talk like that I got that
deadbeat Jimmy shoe but in there you
know at least I Anna's least I have one
of the funniest comics working tonight
as a matter of fact I think he should
ride them into the show leaves doing a
showcase around 8:45 at The Improv I
suggest you go because if not your shows
gonna keep tacking and you're gonna lose
I mean Lee like that yeah and he works
sometimes work yet sometimes it was
sometimes it sometimes it didn't he got
me auditions with Rona crest he got me
audition for the people at that time
that most people could work ten years
and not get on dishes with oh my god
because he would like that [ __ ] that's
why I don't listen to anything did why
do you think I don't listen to anything
there was a time that guy had me doing
three four auditions a day a day a bad
like like dude you had to like I felt
like Baretta the trunk of my car
you know I can put a wig suit coat
changes everything it's been there I
mean he never ended and it was never
like that again I mean there was that I
mean him laugh he took me to alkyl poco
to tell me yeah he took me I'll Kapoor
con la cienega
yeah when they were down the block from
the strip club and he bought me lunch
any cuz I just want a I'm quitting the
money management business yeah I'm going
to Vegas there's a role for you in it if
you want it yeah I'll put you on the
Billboard I was I gonna want but it only
paid $50 the show yeah you have to do
like 18 shows a week I was like that's
not a polite because what you could do
stand-up on
Tuesdays and we stayed friends but his
work ethic always stayed with me and
whenever people would call me and say I
need new headshot
[ __ ] you sell the [ __ ] pictures that
you got and when we sell a job then
we'll get new headshots yeah and that
would be the end of it and it was
because a gallon all the lessons I
learned that even today I think Kevin
would be a little too heavy for today's
family thing yeah he would have burnt
because if he would had six people when
he was told Netflix to go [ __ ] yeah
and I think you're I think he even back
then I think he rubbed people the wrong
way like he said you know there's like I
thought he was a sweetheart I always
thought I see what we this man in the
world
I see but what he got down he was one of
those desert Jews when he rolled the
sleeves dawg
you were going you were going and listen
I did great he booked me in basketball
nice I was gonna have the night before I
shot the scene he drank a gallon the red
wine and we did a lot of other things
and I remember slipping in bed with my
girlfriend and also she's like oh my god
we got to get up I have to drive you to
the Coliseum she thought I had slept all
night I was up all night oh no I meant
for the Coliseum and they're like mr.
Diaz you're the first seen up I'm like
I've been coming here for three [ __ ]
weeks nobody's talked to me I'd do ten
eight-balls and drinking down the red
wine now I'm the first [ __ ] seen up i
stunk like [ __ ] dick I look like dick
can you see bass ketball
and you see me in that scene I was up
all that before that's not not [ __ ]
dust and dude I felt so bad for you
could you get eyes gonna go work on a
set because I kept telling you one more
hour yeah I'm more lying than Ellie no
but you but the funny thing is is I
usually gonna set you got like four or
five hours before they even need you go
over lay down on your trailer but you're
the first seen up proud you not first
see no I basically went home to take a
shower eat something no I didn't even
eat none I drank like a beer making
myself come down and I got into my
girlfriend's car she drove me to the
Coliseum
and I got there and I had to do that
whole scene [ __ ] not Mohammed
I still remember them going step on the
mark mr. Diaz can you please go to the
mark and I'm Mike I am at the mark and
they're like no and finally thank God
some sweet assistant came or she's like
no and by the time I had a shoot there
was no more rollerskates left because I
had stolen all the rollerskates
so in that scene I'm supposed to have
roller skates on none of us have roller
skates on because I couldn't roll oh
yeah when I got the job they asked me if
I could roll escape before I get a job
I'll tell you whatever you want
[Laughter]
if not why somebody else I [ __ ] up
it's the truth it's the [ __ ] truth
you do you tell them whatever you need
can you do a swan dive yeah I did this
one time the day of the shoot because at
the end it's like when Sons of Anarchy
called Jordan and said you have to ride
a motorcycle you know how many people
went in there and said you ride a
motorcycle yeah and then shoot came
today and they're like I never rode a
motorcycle so they put your other
scooter and they pull you and they put
the camera high on you yeah and you
think they think you're driving you're
not driving you wanna she's doing a
puller they're just pulling you and then
you like like make-believe that's a
school that's pulling it you'll need to
learn how to ride a motorcycle I'm sure
that after the first season Jax teller
and there's some of the regulars picked
up my bags paid for them to get lessons
just to do whatever but when you take a
job nine out of ten you'd lie to get
that job I just read a lot of long Yahoo
Chris Moltisanti did you read that in
The Sopranos no never drove a car when
he got their job at the pilot he got a
job it was he was gonna be Tony's driver
right he never said nothing to him that
he couldn't drive so when you're
watching the soprano private pilot did
you call that guy yesterday and [ __ ]
tell him that you were supposed to pick
him up and he's like no
my mother said I shouldn't even come to
work early cuz I was sick and all that
[ __ ] he didn't know how to drive you in
there banging up the car and he goes I'm
done I leave he looked over at James
Gandolfini Jim Daniel Feeney was
laughing and that was what happened
that's why I don't I tell people all the
time tell them whatever they need to
hear remember a [ __ ] sign language
guide they got next to Barack Obama
Dornan Nelson Mandela thing yeah and the
guys like sixteen for the love of and
he's doing the [ __ ] sign language
thing and people watch this going he's
saying the same [ __ ] thing over and
over like he only had three [ __ ]
moves the guy was like you know he's
just [ __ ] about the sign language and
get right next to the president like I'm
gonna that's [ __ ] insane to mean it
you can [ __ ] what about all the sign
language now how many people gonna pick
hope with their death it seems like
every time I watch the Cobra they're
talking like that people she's the chick
with the white hairs it chubby little
black girl that's cute she moves and
Wiggles good no they they make faces
like I was saying to all the skinny guy
for Garcetti he's got to go yeah he's
got autism well no that [ __ ] guy no
that's part of it the animation he's
[ __ ] that guy he's making noise oh
yeah with little things but dude and I
said there might be other bothering me I
said did you see the [ __ ] faces to
make it a go share you'd be making faces
two of your fingers were full of [ __ ] by
cocaine at one 800 K get that blow right
now and he's like I got this guy's the
[ __ ] guy be highways a big jerk-off
out she smells like this how many by the
scientist I guarantee like when I see a
black sign-language person I guarantee
black people hold on what the [ __ ] have
you guys done shows with them on stage
who telling no no but they do they do
colleges yeah a dual I gotta tell you
some bro I'm actually I was gonna take
an online course it's another have a
sign language interpreter because you
know in the middle of a [ __ ] pandemic
you're gonna work you know they said
they got [ __ ] they got people at the
city up draw up to see what you could
sign up the sign language I took two
semesters over in college did you really
yeah it's some terrible languages but
it's English so you're learning you're
learning I can still spell I don't
remember anything because those
[ __ ] are killing it right now
bro yeah that's your new job yes well
you could you go if you could [ __ ] do
that I mean you know you got guys the
federal level that they make pretty good
[ __ ] dough man and they're always
gonna need those you know you know this
I have my favorite Interpol is now in
there Connie I've never seen Cuomo's
interpreter but i sorry caddies got the
skinny guy that looks like Paulie
capital Z can I get with and then the
chick from the whatever in LA the lady
with the stringy hair she was like
Carrie's mother yeah yeah she looks like
[ __ ] them but you see them all and
they all do the same you sit like you
said you get your favorite ones to do it
yeah I got my favorite ones I don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're saying but
it's just interesting watching them and
who the hell you know sometimes is even
a little distracting cuz you're not
watching the guy you're watching decide
I know I always do watch society and I
listen to the other lady you know I had
one of the show cuz I was doing a
benefit and they had one and I was
throwing in words like leather cheerio
just to see what the [ __ ] makeup I
would say and then I stuck it in a
balloon that shit's crazy oh you've been
doing this 33 years man you've seen it
all well it what would this bother you
if this ended our careers I'm like I
said Joey man I look I'd have to figure
something out but I will tell you that
you still part of the magic fallacy
yeah yeah I still do the magic I did I
set up my whole dining room like I have
this bar and I moved it away from the
wall and I pulled my dining room table
except a little kind of like theater so
I can work on some [ __ ] keeps me from
[ __ ] going crazy crazy how I first
time I went the house at the woods or
the Santeria ritual
I seen the two pigeons in the cage I'm
like I don't know Jimmy with the sample
I don't gonna cut some chicken heads off
I need some [ __ ] book some rolls [ __ ]
yeah but then you told me you were a
magician and I was blown away
you have your pigeons do you know I used
two years I didn't let it go into my
mind that Jimmy Sherwood was a magician
I love I love I was being anthem because
I would have stabbed I'm not big on but
you know I'm not about was like my dirty
little secret or II it was one of the
greatest greatest stories I ever heard
and it sounds a lot like dice that you
started as a magician and diced on is it
revolt in person yeah
you know you look at that and how you
started as a magician you told me your
dad would take you down it you have the
cape when you were 14 yeah who Sean you
chose for the Children's Hospital what
team that's why I fell in love with
[ __ ] performing cuz we were six kids
these sick kids were down there and then
all these african-american nurses would
go you gotta come to our church and so I
would do these [ __ ] West Philadelphia
[ __ ] churches never like my dad's
driving me down there with them like he
said that oversized tux you know and
he's got a nine-millimeter on we drop
off at the back door going to the church
do shows but you know Carson was a big
[ __ ] Johnny Carson they have a thing
over there like a whole tribute thing to
Johnny Carson but it's I like it man
it's just something else to do it's like
somebody playing the drums or guitar for
me it's just something that keeps me
saying if I get to work on something
besides [ __ ] this doc up there doc oh
the magician up at the Magic Castle cuz
I know you got into the Magic Castle
yeah yeah the Magic Castle yeah the doc
isse and there's a guy up there that
works but this but you talked to him
yeah what's the one telling your friends
I mean I got 200 people that hate me
he's gotta be in the top three
oh really yeah why because he was a
magician at the at the tower restaurant
in Aspen Colorado in 1983 the towel was
all the towel was on does he talk about
it no but I know doc Eason is a guy that
[ __ ] was a Denver [ __ ] major he's
like one of these guys he's one of the
greatest bar magicians ever so doc
Easton worked at the tower is a magician
during the winter season yeah and what
his angle was was he take a playing card
and then he goes to a tourist and go put
on amount of money there I'm gonna put a
thumbtack under it and there's a reed a
rotating fan if I could throw it up and
stick it in the ceiling I keep the 20 if
it comes down I'd give you your 20 back
plus whatever $20 so every night that
could be out there doing card tricks
I'll be in the back dishwasher I was a
dishwasher a friend of mine knew I
lifted weights and hid the bag so he
goes work with us on prime rib night you
can eat all the prime rib you want I'll
give you all the mistakes that's how I
started working it as I was 18 going on
Tuesday nights we'd do a couple bumps or
coke and and then when I'd have to bring
the glasses out to the bar
I'd watch this dot guy and he'd be doing
this to people all these white people
give me 50 s and hundreds trying to show
off yeah when Texans came up they'd go
up then do it
not do it for 200 man and he would put
water all the bills squish him into the
thumbtack
but the ace of spades over there's nine
of Hearts or write whatever number and
he'd do something and they'd stick on
the ceiling ah goddamn it so one night
after work you know I'm stocking the bar
and I look old and I go I bet I could
jump up there and take that out I'll
blow off the [ __ ] ceiling so look at
the back of the kitchen made sure
everybody was doing their thing and I
went out there maple like I was putting
the barstools up and I just jumped up
and poof I put down a 50 I said [ __ ] it
Wiley stop there sir every night I would
pull down like 150 200 bucks nobody
noticed
not even that [ __ ] Muffy
this one on for about three weeks I was
just pulling down 200 a night Oh a
hundred and eighty and I'd take a bag of
shrimp home I'd go in the closet in the
freeze and just take a bag of shrimp
when I got home by 12:30 my roommate
would get up and make garlic strip of
pasta Jimmy Buerkle god rest his soul
I never told me I never even thought
about the [ __ ] money off the walls
like if you leave money on the walls
you're a jerk-off you deserve to get it
stolen but he wanted to wait till the
end of the season to take it down and
have this big rush for the web
I must adopt him for a couple grand one
day I told the story on a podcast and
about a week later I got an email like a
representative of some [ __ ] to you we
knew we didn't know who was robbing us
they thought it was a different
dishwasher after 30 and they just put
together I was the criminal up there in
1983 I had destroyed that whole system
I'm not proud of it but it happened I
gotta tell you before somebody else does
yeah yeah and so somebody came to me
about a year ago at the store and was
like man I went up to the Comrie castle
and I mentioned your name Oh could I get
a meal oh look how the next time you see
him go up them real casual and then just
drop Joey Diaz sends his love
I watch it that [ __ ] gonna say
oh that's a yes you know our boy Zach
Waldman he works there's any Bravo's
think that anybody he's also he shows
him flappers yeah yeah he works a he
does he works up there all the time
regular basis but that's so funny you'd
love to you that story but doc he's you
know tortured everybody at one time you
know with different people now we've
grown we know it wasn't just me then I
turned everybody else on they were yeah
the Mexican little dishwashers would
like [ __ ] him too yeah they will each
clip in front by the end the [ __ ]
March there was nothing left I think I
left I started working there November 15
and I left February first and I think
the last week was the week I got um even
heavier that they started nosing hmm
something's going on with the money I
probably got him for a couple great I
can't wait to see him up there cuz I
just see if there was a lot of gonna
fight he's gotta be 70 no amen listen
that guy and he's gotta be if I'm if I
was 18 he probably was 26
yeah he's looks good for his age but
you're right he's probably about seven
he's probably like late sixties early
seventies it's crazy I was friends with
him and another great friend of yours
Joe Goliath Joe the Lion of the great
magicians of all all that guy yeah when
I was 16 years old
Michael recently no I've seen he's down
in st. Pete he's down in Florida but I
saw Joe denying when I was a kid and I
am [ __ ] telling you it was one of the
best [ __ ] shows he swords swallowed
he did [ __ ] mind me I'm een he was
like that guy was like college
Entertainer of the Year like three or
four years running I mean he was Joe the
lion was a [ __ ] monster dude I watched
that guy and then I got to work with him
many years later at depending arcade in
Jersey
we've been Creed me and Joe de Lyon was
there he booked it i sat with Joe and I
talked to my tol about that thing what a
great guy
what again the good guy now he was a
great hand was Ben Creed Ben lives in
Arizona I'd not too long ago me and him
just did about a year and a half ago we
did the Atlanta punchline again I mean
him to the to headliner shows it works
yeah dude
hilarious I mean he's gay he was always
well but he's got he's got that dude one
of the funniest [ __ ] lines on his own
he's getting heckled by his woman
just going are you getting it lady if
they had a contest to find the world's
biggest [ __ ] you would come in second he
goes why would I come at second I guess
cuz you're such a couple words but Ben
Creed
send them my love yeah yeah I mean he is
one of those guys he was just like he
was the models a monster 20 years ago
like you know like you said man this
guy's guys love it that you know it's
like you slow down a little bit you get
older it's still like a young man's game
and traveling like you used to now but I
mean you're still doing it still being
able to make a living I think you know a
lot of these cruise ship guys are
screwed for a year that cruise ship
industry ain't coming back anytime soon
and there were some guys that were just
making their living exclusively on
cruise ships I mean that industry's you
know [ __ ] so I think those guys may
rethink some stuff you're right it's
gonna change it's gonna change some
stuff for sure now the album comes out
May 15th yeah the album comes out May 15
what was this tape this was taped
believe it or not flappers we did I did
the album on Friday night and I recorded
my special which is on my website it's
zero tolerance this is the audio from
it's two different two different shows
but I listened to this album I literally
had like for editing notes it's I I'm
telling you bro I'm my own worst critic
I think this is my best comedy album
I've ever done in my life it's a monster
the writing I put into it so look it
drops May 15th all the streaming
platforms iTunes everything people get a
chance to check it out I think it's one
of my best the best comedy I was I'm
really proud of it
I can't wait for it to come out I can't
wait for people to hear it I am a and
when it comes to my own [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
a [ __ ] and so I was like wow I
like twenty two minutes and I don't even
stop to like twenty two minutes in to
take a breath and I take a breath and
the fact is cuz 57 minutes of non-stop
what what did that old-school [ __ ]
stand-up Netflix was great but it took
away and now the country starting to see
it that unless you're a [ __ ] idiot
Netflix is great and the comics on
Netflix are great but I don't want you
just to rely on that that's a whole herd
of comedians that Netflix won't do
business with for whatever reasons they
have then it just is funny or funnier
than all those [ __ ]
Netflix except for maybe [ __ ] bill
burn but I never want you to think that
Netflix is the end-all be-all guys this
guy's out there I've been doing comedy
for 30 years that'll make your [ __ ]
[ __ ] blow up alright from Jimmy
Schubert to Dave Attell to victory
potato oh not just not because they're
on your favorite little [ __ ] [ __ ]
podcast I'm talking about when you get
sick and tired of watching all these
podcast [ __ ] and cooling myself go check
these guys is you're a real comedy fan I
think Jimmy Schubert died same rich vos
guys like Dave Attell that nobody's
talking about it David hell is my
favorite tell there's so many guys out
there Ben creed band creed was dangerous
20 years ago can you imagine the damage
Ben Creed must be doing today yeah and
you over there looking at two [ __ ]
idiots
I'm [ __ ] Netflix because they got a
nice shirt on yeah it's like I'm antenna
we should keep Otello it's time to you
it you knew if you haven't learned
anything from the podcasters they had
you brainwashed with charlie central for
20 years and they thought they were all
the comments they were lost in the
podcast [ __ ] opens up and you guys
get to introduce to real comics you're
like what the [ __ ] is Comedy Central
been showing the statement showing us
fluff for [ __ ] 20 years then comedy
then then [ __ ] the podcast came along
and you got introduced to them the
Netflix came along and you got
introduced to those cats don't ever
[ __ ] just think that those are the
guys are they're out there doing it you
get on YouTube you're bored you type up
victim attend oh you've got type up
Jimmy Schubert you type up [ __ ] Ben
Creed this that the bobby slate waiting
Bobby Slayton got less funny you know he
got older and angrier now he's saying
racial slurs outward he don't give a
[ __ ] you know now is when you go catch
these guys number one Rudy was here and
told me that I had to go catch two
legends before they died now I can't I
did go see Guns & Roses and I did go see
Pat Benatar and I was exposed to a whole
different world that helped me to be a
better comic yeah so don't just sit
there in your house
she's [ __ ] Netflix thinking this is
the end all be all those comics are
great I love half of them and dear
friends to me but if you're a real
comedy kind of saw Jimmy Schubert rich
vos you know these are the guys have
been doing it that maybe because I don't
have a fancy podcast or maybe because
they're not good at social networking
you haven't paid attention to him
change your [ __ ] around you dumb
[ __ ] look what you learned from
the podcast Comedy Central was selling
you [ __ ] they've been selling you [ __ ]
for 20 [ __ ] years then we came along
but look comedy central enough they had
a pre draft the [ __ ] David Spade show
like they got rid of the David Spade
show how they show in the world they
gotta look for another house what they
do moves that only like it they might as
well join with New England you know I'm
saying yeah that the New England's
management might as well join up with
Tommy I don't think ever did and get rid
of [ __ ] Tom Brady I would have put a
gun to his [ __ ] head and said I won't
shoot you cut in the [ __ ] you were
staying right here in New England
Tobey I don't know whether you like it
or not you're not going nowhere
yeah the only way you leave here is with
Corona a bullet in your head or dwarvish
Taylor make a comeback and brace your
leg you're not going nowhere
yeah ain't greghowes you know these guys
cuz I'll [ __ ] hit you with a crane
you big [ __ ]
you'll be squeezing oranges on a [ __ ]
that in a [ __ ] Mexican night bar in
Tijuana you [ __ ] Boethius you don't let
your people go like that new time or
whatever
I'm ashamed urban this country's excited
for football except the New England
people yeah they're sitting up there
getting weaker or they'll want the
corona they get yeah half of them are in
the streets give it to me cuz I can't
live without Tom Brady what the [ __ ]
that little short side of life right now
oh right now if you're a Boston guy you
want to kill that guy got the angle
hi yourself a hot little Chinese girl
with gloves on - just knock on his door
he loves those we'll try these head jobs
what's the name Robert Robert crap the
do anything for a little cheeky winky
[ __ ] you say give me the Robert Kraft
give me Robert Kraft for dry what
I got that that [ __ ] I feel so
bad my heart goes off so bad to boss
them right now
yeah I grew up a Boston everything I
love I reached I respected Celtics I
can't wait
a [ __ ] Michael Jordan that thing has
been tremendous but you know did this
whole thing you left the city that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about football no
more wow yeah that's not the way their
heart and their kidney they walk [ __ ]
New England pages on October machine
right now wishing they could die filthy
but now again I don't know what I was a
little man Edelman that tire a little
bit he went down there Gronk went down
there and and that'll been left to I'm
not still here
oh yes don't give him an envelope
that'll make his head straight don't
they'll send him a beanie stop with all
our bills that's as I got old Israelis
message cousin I think when you put the
fish in the thing these sleeps with the
fishes
that's what Kraft is gonna get next so
yeah with a hundred olive bill means
give a settlement dude so funny you were
talking about gold Cena I remember like
I said I was just brag garrett's Club I
had dinner before thinking but Brad I
told him I don't I said I saw him open
for Sinatra at the [ __ ] sands back
when I was working with Kinnison at the
[ __ ] dunes and we had an off night
and he goes hey man I got some [ __ ]
tickets to go see Sinatra you want to go
and I was like you know his girls are
the security got one exercise know what
he wanted ya [ __ ] seat Sinatra we've
got to sit in a [ __ ] booth watch
Sinatra do a [ __ ] line and Brad
Garrett [ __ ] Oprah for though
listen I want to date you or me but I
said I watched you [ __ ] over for him
and like you know he goes oh yeah so
that's what I love what you do Brad Brad
Garrett's club he's got all the history
like the there's contracts pictures with
Sinatra all the stuff I mean that guy's
had an amazing [ __ ] career but but
what if we'll get a nice guy what a
really great
I love doing I worked with him on the
Showtime thing I spent the [ __ ] a couple
days of them I didn't know what to
expect
I'd love to get him on the show he's got
a he's a great guy Brad Garrett oh yeah
Jimmy two-shoes the 15th of May 15th of
May so that's the [ __ ] you we're
gonna call it the the [ __ ] covin CD
of the month hey man keep people out of
the [ __ ] rap knowledge baby they find
it you go well it'll be a big
announcement of Jimmy Schubert calm but
it'll be on iTunes it'll be everywhere
they stream
it's called zero tolerance may 15th mark
the calendars it's a solid [ __ ] hour
of [ __ ] straight stand-up set up
punchlines and callbacks oh yeah check
it out and you'll be happy you did well
I'm happy you came in this Monday more
amantha thank you for having me uncle
Joey man you know I love you brother
down I did some last week that was very
disrespectful on the podcast and I
apologize for my professional people but
we're gonna make up for it right now I
had a guest on but I its corona season
so I didn't wanna insult anybody and
whip out a bomb but in honor of melee
and Jimmy shoe but I'm gonna do a quick
z100 pack this is a hundred milligrams
what vitamins in it melatonin to help
you take a nice long nap and out of
respect and I'll never do it again to
you guys I promise from the bottom of my
heart I think we had these on that day
didn't know we didn't do [ __ ] and do
another ball we got into an edible till
last night did one little capsule and I
was fine no we didn't do you think I
gave it to me then no you didn't have
nothing so I didn't want you think that
were weak we have no dates okay I have
no dates I have June 4th through the 6th
and Brahe I don't know if it's gonna
happen if you want to come you come if
you don't want to come from which I
don't want you to be scared or be
worried but this all goes to you
[ __ ] on the for 4:20 out of
respect to you guys for being the best
church family in the world salut salut
[ __ ]
you can't walk on one leg [ __ ] have a
great day thank you very much have a
great week and we'll be back Wednesday
to rock your [ __ ] world kick this
[ __ ] mealy
[Music]